[Music]
[Music]
estamos algo say horas de la serda
Mexico
en Arjun de la montaña alta es una zona
margin Arizona's own indigenous una zona
que caresses de mucho recursos para para
ser la cirugía en este tipo da spittle
Desa de Traer medicina de bajo costo de
facil accesso asana Relays con el apoyo
de really add virtual
[Music]
dr. jose luis moso Vasquez is a surgeon
at the pan american university in mexico
city
dr. Musa uses virtual reality as a
painkiller in the operating room
allowing him to use local anesthetic
instead of putting his patients under in
polemic on all Sonesta sequestration
Alice a teen en algunas ventajas andreas
el alto cost
he lost efectos collateral is what
varus's he operates on patients with
afflictions like cysts and tumors using
VR to distract them Saeko loca knows
Lente's bill to Alice say Houston de
acuerdo Altima no su cabeza y sensient a
el sistema de la bento al que se hace
commune teléfono celular
actual meant a yo Meerut planter to be
IC o menos yeah just out there be no no
speaka Tito's little pero no nowhere see
tremendous emos el pollo a Mazda
cincuenta por ciento en estos fazenda a
los pacientes less de una gran esperanza
de sobre be de él está una mejor calidad
de vida na me hace sentir una persona
satisfaction sophistical Evita
satisfy choco la Vida professional Mia
permitido de Savoie d'Armes de volver la
sociedad leukemia general
[Music]
[Music]
we saw a few patients that were blind
yesterday and now they are seen today I
have personally done surgeries on more
than hundred thirty thousand patients I
grew up in a very small village
northeast of Nepal I lost my brother and
sisters to such simple diseases that
could have been cured by modern medicine
and that's why it has become my mission
in life to be a doctor for the poor
there are so many people that I can help
I am dr. sondik Drouet I am the North a
neurologist and executive director of
the tale instead of ophthalmology here
in Nepal which caters to about 500,000
to 1 million people many Nepalese and
rural villages are losing their eyesight
90% of the blind actually lives in this
part of the world cataract as a disease
can cloud your vision for life surgery
is the only treatment for cataract so I
travel to remote villages all over my
country since I know from my own
experience people who are marginalized
both because of economy and geography
they are the ones who suffer a lot the
longest that I have travels is working
for other same days with the equipment's
I have these big eye opening stables
it's kind of a moment where I've seen
hundreds of patients you are probably
working for thirteen hours a day
everybody thought I am crazy and mad
we wanted to find surgical technique and
a surgical system which was
cost-effective intraocular lenses which
are a must part of modern cataract
surgery used to cost 250 to 300 dollars
we worked very very hard to bring down
the cost of these lenses to less than
three dollars by being able to
manufacture in Nepal
[Music]
I've seen thousands for each patient
story touches my heart and it is the
expression of these patients who have
been blind yesterday and suddenly they
come out and see everything in front of
them see people they loved and they
changed the perspective to life
in a fraction of second we have been
seeing some good effects of our work in
the last ten years we have trained
nearly 650 doctors and I believe that we
can do this all over the world and I
want to spend the rest of my life
raising money for many of these
hospitals this is why this medical
intervention is so beautiful and so
powerful my patients are my life and
soul
[Music]
this is Myron hi Myron is an athlete I
played a little football in college and
I was a Rhodes Scholar and I played for
the NFL and I have a master's degree in
medical anthropology and and I'm a
neurosurgeon sheesh
[Music]
my first dream was to play professional
football that's no question you I was
very active as a young man and I knew
that I was pretty good at it
I guess it a fifth grade that's when I
knew I wanted to pursue my second dream
I read a book called gifted hands by Ben
Carson who looked like me he was black
who came from a similar socioeconomic
background as me you know we'd have much
money when we left the Bahamas that came
to America and if more I read about it
the more I knew that once I was done
playing football neurosurgery was gonna
be the pathway in the second chapter of
my life I was the number one ready to
high school player in the country for
football
recruited by everyone eighty-three
scholarship offers I always felt that
football fed academics academics fed
football Myron spent his college years
playing football and shadowing doctors
he graduated in two and a half years and
was expected to be a first or
second-round draft pick in the NFL with
a multi-million dollar contract but he
also had a chance to study at Oxford as
a Rhodes Scholar I ended up deciding to
go to Oxford and saying no to the NFL
and spent a year and a half over there I
came back to the United States went into
the draft and got drafted in the sixth
round instead of the second or first
made $70,000 instead of six million
played for three years got out healthy
felt good about my time there and
frankly made enough money to pay for
medical school I didn't have any lasting
concussions and my hands were okay where
I was able to do surgeries in the
operating room and so I left on my own
volition started medical school and Here
I am now since head injuries are common
on the football field
Myron works to impress the importance of
avoiding concussions on young players
but from Myron his days of tackling are
behind him football was great for that
season of my life but now this is it
this is the pinnacle this is this is
where I belong and I've told my parents
several times over and over again they
asked me my heart how do you feel what
you're doing now how do you feel I said
mommy and daddy I feel like this is
where I belong
yes
[Music]
c-sections are the most common major
surgery performed on human beings over
basically one generation of moms the
c-section rate has gone up at 500%
problem is that your number one risk for
having a c-section might be which
hospital you go to that's what wakes me
up in the morning Emile Shaw and
obstetrician over at Beth Israel
Deaconess Medical Center I'm an
assistant professor at Harvard Medical
School and I'm part of the core faculty
here at Ariadne labs a lot of people
don't realize the full magnitude of the
problem with c-sections basically in the
late 1960s early 1970s he section rates
are about 5% and then all of a sudden
the c-section rate starts to skyrocket
not just increase but skyrocket so
before the end of the century the
c-section rate goes up to one and three
and we don't really have a great idea
why this is happening as a surgeon
myself it's hard to believe that one in
three human beings needs a major surgery
to be born but that's sort of where we
are right now and the consequences are
significant so things like severe
infection hemorrhage organ injury in
addition to five billion dollars of
spending annually we're talking
something like 20,000 major avoidable
surgical complications we're seeing from
c-sections we didn't need to do in the
first place
I was really puzzled when I first
started this job thinking like what can
we possibly do about this epidemiologist
economists policymakers lots of people
have been thinking about this for a long
time the clue for me was the fact that
across the country c-section rates vary
from 7 percent to 70 percent the
hospital
if Hospital performance is so uneven and
it's not explained by patient risk or
patient preference that means the
hospital itself could be a risk factor
all of our projects right now are
actually trying to figure out what makes
hospital a different from hospital B
what we've seen is that oftentimes the
labor floors and kind of like a almost
forgotten about corner and it just
doesn't get a lot of investment or an
attention from the hospital when we
visit a bunch of different hospitals who
realize that they're laid out very
differently and that might matter for
example there are no rules for how many
labor floor rooms you should have based
on the amount of patients that you see
the place that does twice as many
deliveries also does way more c-sections
the only way that's possible is if
they're moving people through much
faster almost all labor floors seem
really tight on resources so the idea is
when you have a huge surge in patient
volume how do you flexibly recruit more
rooms how do you bring in more staff
you've reported c-section rates back to
your doctors like I have no idea what my
c-section rate is until somebody tells
me you know we're testing this
hypothesis that management matters in
childbirth just solely it matters in
every other industry we're starting to
parse differences among c-section so
rather than looking at all c-sections
altogether we're trying to just take the
lowest risk women and focus on their
c-section rate
as soon as you start to do that two
things happen insurance companies start
to pay attention and then just women
start to pay attention and I actually
think this is an area where women's
views on this are probably going to be
the driving force behind the change
there's really no other moment in
people's life where they're so
discerning as when they become pregnant
[Music]